California became the first sanctuary
state in the country this year when it
enacted new legislation to prevent law
enforcement from carrying out president
Trump's crackdown on the undocumented
but now fears here are growing amid
reports that ice is planning to launch a
massive sweep targeting Northern
California there are almost 400 thousand
undocumented immigrants in the San
Francisco Bay Area alone and we're about
to visit the Oakland home of an
undocumented woman who is preparing her
family for the worst wendy is a 34 year
old single mother from Honduras who
cleans houses for a living her two
children were born in the US she fled
extreme poverty and remains undocumented
after living here for 15 years but she's
defiant despite the threat of possible
deportation why are you so unafraid to
the point where your occasional
in-your-face you know work I for one
time is scared and one day I say I
stopped by no more cuando vas a ver que
llamo strano de que no tengo no teemo's
que tener miedo y tenemos que que hacer
lo que nosotros NT Moshe queremos some
of my horns almost mask artists
well no tienes miedo today have gotta be
sauteing they have scared not just cause
of 40 mala has his party Miedema she
isn't only talking about ice Wendy's
partner was abusive for years and nearly
killed her until she ultimately escaped
with her children to a women's shelter
now she only fears one thing deportation
a yellow cotton was porque soy la única
kizaki yuria no tiene mi familia que si
si tengo os8 amor no tengo miedo sino
que son tomorrow como de que seguir a
pasar Chiapas are con ellos the recent
threats of massive raids have prompted
Wendy and others like her to literally
prepare for their nightmare scenario
there's a Buddhist back so that duffel
bag yeah like your back like an
emergency bag just in case you have to
go yeah
I'm saying me go I only carry them
that's it what do you have in there you
don't have to show me but I have a
clothes for my kid took her to change
for my son - for my daughter into for me
Wow
yeah this is the that car you know
probably see the nigga come to my house
I take this Caracalla in Spanish in
English you know it's for the incase ice
comes here yeah yeah this a new or a la
puerta y una gente de servicio de
inmigración esta tocando a la puerta no
contest en gonna pregunta de la de la
gente del servicio de inmigración CL
trata de hablar con usted y usted tiene
derecho a Montaner say que yo no tiene
que dar su nombre and then how else are
you preparing what else do you have ah
because I have my papers my son do come
on you know yeah the certificate for it
one my son hmm my daughter papers thing
my casa por yes surely I have hmm this
is more important you have a with me
every day
how are you know how about the process
over the u-visa
and I how are we me something
happened so you have everything prepared
yeah at all times with you yeah hi this
holder we meet every day are your kids
scared or at least her sons was older
yeah
he crying for now here he looking at
nothing
here there are other people my mom was
here - my mama's the poor he crying I
said only I depended humans what's going
on with me my sister - you must hear my
I wake up every day you know I asked him
that please
paper in your hand take care of me and
my family and every day when I go
outside and I say I don't ask Erica us
with me you take care of me and my
family and for right now is work
hey everyone it's Deena make sure you
check out more of my videos and the
direct from playlist be sure to like
comment share and subscribe to aj+